thinking about product Improvement is
really hard because what does that mean
but just thinking about what are the
problems every single problem in as
nuanced details I possibly can about the
customer experience both perceived and
actual that the customer is going
through from before they start to use
the product all the way through the end
and after the result are experiencing
the result of the product every single
microstep that occurs on that process
how can I lubricate that how can I make
it faster and easier for them so that
when they get to that they just click
cheat code and then they move through